[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend dass man in Russland
den Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
nicht Krieg nennen darf sondern
spezialoperation das ist ja bekannt als
Präsident Putin heute das Wort Krieg
selber benutzte brauchte man ganz kurz
auf allerdings wirklich nur ganz kurz
denn er benutzte es in einer Art und
Weise die man nur schwer ertragen kann
sie haben den Krieg losgetreten sagte er
in Richtung westlicher Staaten Russland
versuche lediglich die Kämpfe zu beenden
seine Rede an die Nation war voll von
solchen Vorwürfen auf die US-Präsident
beiden wiederum bei seiner Rede in
Warschau reagierte und an das russische
Volk appellierte über das Fernduell
Annegret Oster
es sind eindeutige Bilder einer
eindeutigen Reise
der Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten
kommt aus Kiew und betritt am Abend die
Bühne in Warschau und wendet sich an das
russische Volk
die USA und Europa wollen Russland nicht
kontrollieren oder zerstören wir wollen
Russland auch nicht attackieren wie
Putin heute behauptet hat dieser Krieg
ist keine Notwendigkeit
sondern eine Tragödie Putin kann den
Krieg mit einem einzigen Wort beenden
rund 20 Minuten spricht beiden
entschlossen glasklar und sehr emotional
es ist die Antwort auf Putins große Rede
zur Lage der Nationen am Vormittag in
Moskau ein Jahr nach Beginn des
ukrainekrieges und die beginnt mit
seiner Wahrheit
die Verantwortung für das Schüren des
ukraine-konflikts für seine Eskalation
für die vielen Opfer liegt vollständig
bei den westlichen Eliten und natürlich
bei der ukrainischen Regierung für die
die Ukraine ein komplett fremdes Volk
ist
ein
neonazi-regime sei dort an der Macht so
das narrativ des kreml-chefs daher werde
die militärische spezial-operation wie
Moskau den Krieg bezeichnet fortgesetzt
ich möchte es noch einmal sagen sie
haben den Krieg begonnen und wir haben
Gewalt eingesetzt und tun das immer noch
um ihn zu beenden
Applaus für Putins Wahrheit der von ihm
befohlene Krieg gegen die Ukraine mit
tausenden zivilen Opfern eine Art
Geiselbefreiung
beides Antwort eindeutig
die Ukraine wird niemals von Russland
besiegt werden niemals
der Appetit von Autokraten kann niemals
gestillt werden er muss gestoppt werden
Autokraten verstehen nur ein einziges
Wort nein
am Ende seiner eher erwartbaren Rede
lässt Putin dann eine politische Bombe
platzen der russische Präsident kündigt
an den letzten großen Abrüstungsvertrag
mit den USA auszusetzen
ich sehe mich dazu gezwungen ich
wiederhole wir kündigen ihn nicht aber
wir ziehen uns vorerst daraus zurück
diese Aussage wird im Nachhinein vom
russischen Außenministerium relativiert
die USA kritisieren die Ankündigung als
unverantwortlich und beiden warnt
Russland unverhohlen
es gibt keinen Zweifel die USA stehen
hinter der NATO felsenfest
jedes Mitglied der NATO und auch
Russland weiß ein Angriff auf einen ist
ein Angriff auf alle das ist ein
heiliger Schwur
einen deutlichen Block hätte beiden
nicht einschlagen können in Warschau die
Positionen sind klar und weiter
auseinander könnten sie nicht liegen
um die 1200 Kilometer liegen zwischen
Moskau und Warschau die Distanz zwischen
Putin und beiden lässt sich auch das
haben diese beiden Reden gezeigt gar
nicht mehr messen aber einordnen und
zwar von MRT Wissen unserem Studioleiter
aus Washington der den US-Präsidenten
begleitet und für begann unsere
Studioleiterin aus Moskau guten Abend an
euch beide Vögel eine Rede wir haben es
gerade gehört voller Vorwürfe aber keine
große Ankündigung wie bewertest du die
Rede auf die ja auch alle mit Spannung
gewartet haben
ja gerade auch durch das Timing so kurz
vor dem Jahrestag des Krieges da hatten
auch viele Russinnen und Russen sich
eine Art Richtungsanzeige von ihrem
Präsidenten erhofft was der dann
geliefert hat das war aber er
überfällige Pflichterfüllung als eben
die große Vision davon wie Vladimir
Putin die Zukunft russland sieht zwei
Dinge sind an dieser Rede bemerkenswert
erstens wladimir Putin hat die
Gelegenheit wieder einmal genutzt für
seine Behauptung dass Russland nicht
gegen die Bevölkerung in der Ukraine
Krieg führe sondern sich in einem
Konflikt mit dem Westen befindet aus
dieser Behauptung folgt für den
russischen Präsidenten die Konsequenz
dass er den Abrüstungsvertrag mit
Amerika ruhen lassen möchte und zweitens
wladimir Putin hat nicht davon
gesprochen wie dieser Krieg enden könnte
stattdessen erklärte er zum Beispiel das
russische Soldaten alle sechs Monate
einen Heimaturlaub von der Front
bekommen sollten das zeigt das für
Vladimir Putin dieser Krieg auf lange
Zeit noch ein fester Bestandteil des
russischen all das ist und darauf hat er
sein Volk und die Eliten heute
eingestellt
immer und damit zu dir beiden also der
US-Präsident hat ja ein sehr besonderen
Ort für seinen Auftritt gewählt das
Warschauer Königsschloss hat er denn
auch besondere Worte gewählt
ja ich glaube das hat er klargemacht
dass es hier um die Freiheit geht und
dass die Welt eben an einem Scheideweg
steht sich entscheiden muss zwischen
Autoritarismus und Demokratie und der
regelbasiert in Ordnung wir konnten vor
ein paar Minuten mit sehr engen Berater
und von Joe Biden hier sprechen wir
dürfen die Namen nicht nennen das sind
die Regeln aber wir können sagen was Sie
gesagt haben und sie sehen zum Beispiel
in der Ankündigung von Putin aus dem new
start-abkommen auszusteigen eigentlich
nur eine Widerspiegelung der Realität
denn seit mehr als sechs Monaten lässt
Russland schon keinen Inspektoren mehr
hinein um die Atomwaffen zu
kontrollieren und beteiligt sich auch
nicht mehr an Gesprächen während
gleichzeitig russische Inspektoren in
die USA hinein dürfen die USA haben das
vor drei Wochen auch schon öffentlich
gemacht Russland deswegen den Bruch des
Abkommens vorgeworfen und das Putin das
jetzt in seine redepakt gewissermaßen
als Ankündigung das wird ja eher als ein
Zeichen der Schwäche angesehen als als
Stärke und insofern sagen die USA ganz
klar man steht unerschütter sprich
weiter hinter der Ukraine und zwar damit
sie eine bestmögliche
Verhandlungsposition bekommt für
mögliche Verhandlungen irgendwann wenn
Putin bereit ist von seinen
maximalzielen abzugehen
soweit die Einschätzungen Einschätzungen
unser Studioleiter aus Moskau und Elmar
der den US-Präsidenten begleitet aus
Warschau vielen herzlichen Dank und wir
haben es gerade von mrtsen gehört new
start dieser Abrüstungsvertrag ist ja
das einzige noch verbliebene große
Abkommen zur Rüstungskontrolle zwischen
den USA und Russland worum es konkret
geht kurz und kompakt von Christian
Kirsch
[Musik]
seit dem Ende des Kalten Krieges
versuchen Russland und die USA als
bedeutendste Atommächte den Umfang ihrer
atomarsennale vertraglich zu regeln
derzeit so Schätzungen gibt es weltweit
rund 12.700 Atomwaffen davon sind etwa
30% einsatzbereit unter Kontrolle der
USA etwa 1750 mindestens 1588 im Besitz
Russlands
um dieses Niveau zu erreichen haben die
beiden Supermächte die 90% aller
Atomwaffen besitzen mehrere Verträge
geschlossen
1987 etwa den INF-Vertrag der die
Vernichtung von Kernwaffen mit kürzerer
und mittlerer Reichweite regelt
1991 trat dann das start-abkommen
strategic arms reduction Treaty in Kraft
ein Abrüstungsvertrag mit dem new
start-abkommen von 2011 wird dieser
Abrüstungsprozess aktuell fortgesetzt
der startvertrag regelt die Höchstmenge
an nuklearen Sprengköpfen und
Trägersystemen diesen Vertrag setzt
Russland laut Putin nun aus
tja was würde es bedeuten wenn der new
startvertrag wirklich enden oder
ausgesetzt werden würde eine Antwort
darauf hat sicherlich dr Claudia major
sie ist sicherheits- und
verteidigungsexpertin der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik und zudem im
Beirat zivile Krisenprävention und
Friedensförderung der Bundesregierung
und damit ein schönen guten Abend nach
Berlin guten Abend können Sie uns kurz
erklären was es bedeuten würde
also tatsächlich würde sich praktisch
nicht viel verändern aber es ist
langfristig eine extrem beunruhigende
Entwicklung kurzfristig sind tatsächlich
die Inspektion seit Corona und dann seit
Kriegsbeginn ausgesetzt und Russland hat
die Konsultation auch abgesagt das heißt
praktisch ändert sich da gerade nicht
sehr viel zumal das russische
Außenministerium auch gesagt hat dass
sie sich weiter an die Obergrenze halten
wollen aber das Problem ist vor allen
Dingen langfristig weil der new
startvertrag 2026 auslaufen würde und
Russland mit der Entscheidung heute klar
gemacht hat dass sie überhaupt keine
Interesse daran haben diesen Vertrag
vorzusetzen und das damit die letzte
Begrenzung für die russischen und
amerikanischen nuklear Arsenale
wegfallen würden das heißt danach ist
eigentlich der Weg offen für eine große
Aufrüstung und die ist extrem
beunruhigend ein fast schon Rückfall in
alte Zeiten Stichwort Wettrüsten der
russische Präsident hat ja ansonsten
heute nicht besonders viel Neues gesagt
er hat auch keine zweite russische
mobilmachungs
beispielsweise angekündigt sehen Sie das
als Schwäche oder als Strategie
ich sehe das vor allen Dingen als ein
weiter so also diese Rede war ja ein
sehr großes weiter so und Wiederholen
von alten Vorwürfen das haben wir ihre
Kolleginnen auch schon eben gesagt also
die alten Vorwürfe gingen mit den Westen
und verstehst uns in der Ukraine aber im
Endeffekt sehe ich die Rede so dass Sie
dass er Russland auf einen langfristigen
Krieg gegen den Westen einschwört und
dieses Element mit dem new start
Suspendierung ist ein Zeichen dafür dass
es ein langer Krieg und langer Konflikt
werden wird und das Russland kein
Interesse an der Eskalation und vor
allen Dingen kein Interesse an
diplomatischen Lösungen hat und das ist
für mich daran dass beunruhigende
Element die Langfristigkeit und die
Absage an jegliche Art von Diplomatie
jetzt muss man ja eines festhalten Putin
hat im Grunde von allem mehr Menschen
die er in den Krieg schicken kann und
vor allen Dingen auch mehr Munition die
Russen sollen pro Tag mehr Geschosse
verschießen als in der EU in einem Monat
produziert werden keiner weiß also wohin
dieser Krück eigentlich dieser Krieg
noch führt geschweige denn wie beenden
könnte auch das haben wir gerade gehört
haben Sie eine Idee
also man sagt vereinfacht das Kriege auf
drei artenenten entweder gewinnt eine
von beiden Seiten das ist gerade nicht
die Situation oder beide Seiten sind so
erschöpft dass sie vom aufhören größere
Vorteile haben als vom weitermachen das
haben wir gerade auch nicht Russland
glaubt es kann noch mehr Gelände erobern
die Ukraine hofft es kann noch mehr
Gelände sie kann noch mehr Gelände
befreien oder die dritte Variante ist
dass sich die politische Situation in
einem der beiden Länder so fundamental
ändert dass der Krieg weniger wichtig
wird momentan haben wir keins von den
drei Situationen deshalb wäre meiner
Einschätzung nach die Aufgabe der
westlichen Unterstützung darauf
hinzuarbeiten das Russland kein Gewinn
mehr daran sieht diesen Krieg
vorzusetzen also Russland de facto
militärisch an den Verhandlungstisch zu
zwingen damit es mehr Gewinn oder mehr
benefit darin sieht diesen Krieg
aufzuhören als weiter zu machen jetzt
wäre verhandeln ja theoretisch auch noch
eine Option da heißt es immer das geht
eigentlich nur aus einer gestärkten
Ukraine heraus
wie sehen Sie das naja es finden ja
Verhandlungen statt es finden regelmäßig
Gespräche zwischen der Ukraine und
Russland statt zum Beispiel über
gefangenenaustausche auch zwischen den
USA und Russland und auch der Kanzler
telefoniert mit Putin aber wir müssen
uns glaube ich nichts vormachen bislang
hat Russland kein Interesse daran gehabt
Verhandlung zu führen die diesen Krieg
beenden russland hat bislang gesagt dass
Verhandlungen über das Kriegsende immer
heißt das zuvor die Ukraine anerkennen
muss dass die viel besetzten
annektierten Gebiete und die krimen denn
jetzt Johannes saporica und die Krim als
russisch anerkannt werden das ist dann
aber keine Verhandlung das ist de facto
eine ukrainische Kapitulation und
deshalb noch mal müsste eigentlich das
Ziel sein Russland ohne Vorbedingungen
an den Verhandlungstisch zu kriegen Frau
Maja sie waren ja auch auf der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz sie haben dort
genauso wie heute bei der Rede von
beiden eine Art mantrage gehört wir
stehen an der Seite der Ukraine wir
halten durch je öfter man gehört desto
mehr wirkt es fast schon so wie eine wie
soll man es formulieren selbst
Vergewisserung wie deuten sie das
ich habe in der Tat Sorge dass wir nach
über einem Jahr Krieg in so einer Art in
den westlichen Staaten so eine Art
Kriegsmüdigkeit gelangen und dass das
Interesse an dem Krieg
singt das ist weniger Unterstützung gibt
weil andere Themen wichtiger werden weil
die Kosten bei uns spürbarer werden und
das sehe ich als sehr großes Risiko weil
die Ukraine diesen Krieg nur dann
fortsetzen und im besten Falle gewinnen
kann wenn sie weiterhin politische
finanzielle und militärische
Unterstützung durch die westlichen
Staaten erhält man sagt in der Regel
dass ein Krieg der gewinnt der immer
wieder seine Lücken stopfen kann also
finanziell aber auch militärisch und
dafür hängt die Ukraine von den
westlichen Staaten ab und deswegen ist
diese diese Kriegsmüdigkeit ein enormes
Risiko
soweit die Einschätzungen von Dr Claudia
major sicherheits- und
verteidigungsexpertin der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik und damit
herzlichen Dank nach Berlin alles Gute
ich danke Ihnen
und damit schließen wir diesen Komplex
ab und blicken auf eine andere
Katastrophe die schweren Erdbeben im
türkisch-syrischen Grenzgebiet haben ja
zu einer Katastrophe unfassbaren
Ausmaßes geführt zwei deutsche
Ministerinnen waren heute vor Ort und
damit beginnen deine Nachrichten haben
ganz genau Außenministerin beerburg und
Innenministerin ferser haben das
Erdbebengebiet in der Türkei besucht und
den Betroffenen umfangreiche Hilfe und
langfristige Unterstützung zugesagt zu
kündigte Werbung an die Finanzhilfen auf
108 Millionen Euro aufzustocken und
damit fast zu verdoppeln durch das Beben
sollen laut neuen Behörden Angaben mehr
als 48.000 Menschen getötet worden sein
gestern wurde die Region zudem erneut
durch zwei schwere Erdbeben erschüttert
laut dem türkischen Katastrophenschutz
stieg die Zahl der Toten auf mindestens
sechs und die der Verletzten auch fast
300 auf syrische Medienberichten über
Tote nach den neuen Beben zahlreiche
Gebäude stürzten ein
neun Tage nach der Wiederholung der Wahl
zum Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus haben sich
die bisherigen Koalitionsparteien SPD
Grüne und Linke zu einem ersten
Sondierungsgespräch getroffen Berlins
Regierende Bürgermeisterin gfay von der
SPD und Grünen
spitzenkandidatinarasch favorisieren
eine Neuauflage von Rot-Grün Roth zuvor
hatte bereits die CDU die bei der Wahl
am 12 februar die meisten Stimmen
erhielt erste Gespräche mit Grünen und
SPD geführt
angesichts des Fachkräftemangels in
Deutschland haben entwicklungsministerin
Schulze und Arbeitsminister Heil in
Ghana für eine legale Zuwanderung in den
deutschen Arbeitsmarkt geworben bei
ihrem Besuch in dem westafrikanischen
Land vereinbarten die Minister dazu eine
engere Zusammenarbeit so will man
künftig auswanderungswillige Ganache
Fachkräfte gezielter fördern zudem
sollen rund 10 Millionen Euro in die
Ausbildung von Arbeitskräften vor Ort
investiert werden
trotz der seit Wochen andauernden
Massenproteste hat das israelische
Parlament in der nach zentralen Teilen
der umstrittenen Justizreform in erster
Lesung zugestimmt die Gesetzentwürfe
geben der rechtsreligiösen Regierung
unter anderem mehr Mitspracherecht bei
der Besetzung von Richterinnen und
Richtern außerdem sollen Urteile des
höchsten Gerichts künftig vom Parlament
aufgehoben werden können kritiker sehen
dadurch die Unabhängigkeit der Justiz in
Israel gefährdet
in Iran ist heute ein Aktivist wegen
terrorvorwürfen bzw Zitat Korruption auf
Erden schuldig gesprochen worden
schuldig bedeutet in diesem Falle zum
Tode verurteilt die Geschichte um den
deutsch-it schamad klingt wirklich wie
aus einem ganz schlechten Film bei einem
Zwischenstopp in Dubai vom iranischen
Geheimdienst entführt nach Iran
verschleppt vor Gericht gebracht Prozess
ohne freie Wahl eines Anwalts dieser
Fall schlägt auch hier bei uns in
Deutschland wählen Gründe und
Hintergründe jetzt von Kamran Safi
ihm droht der Tod durch den Strang Jam
she the shore macht 67 Jahre alt Deutsch
iranischer Staatsbürger Kim Kreise
seiner Familie
seit 2020 sitzt er in Iran in Haft die
Anklage gegen ihn lautet Korruption auf
Erden wir erreichen seine Tochter
rasolle in den USA ich bin völlig
schockiert das ist grauenvoll das ist
ein Urteil gegen ein Aktivisten gibt es
das ist ein Todesurteil gegen einen
deutschen Staatsbürger der nichts
gemacht hat außer die Stimme der
Menschen im Iran gewesen ist das letzte
Mal als anrufen durfte hat er meine
Mutter gesagt er hat keine Zähne mehr
die wurden ihm ausgeschlagen er ist dort
unter Folter er hat uns und bekommt
seine Medikamente nicht
Kalifornien hier lebte Jam viele Schaum
macht aufgewachsen ist er in Deutschland
im Sommer 2020 wieder nach Indien reisen
bei einem Stopp in Dubai wird er vom
iranischen Geheimdienst nach Teheran
verschleppt
das Staatsfernsehen zeigt ein Geständnis
Tehran wirft ihm vor mit seinem
oppositionssender Ton dar das Regime
bekämpft zu haben und er soll für einen
Anschlag auf eine Moschee
mitverantwortlich sein sagt das Regime
ernesty international sieht das anders
gehen darauf an hat es nichts zu tun
macht bekommt prominente Unterstützung
aus rein der Politik der CDU-Vorsitzende
Friedrich Merz hat die politische
Patenschaft für ihn übernommen wir
erreichen ihn in den USA ich fordere die
Bundesregierung auf jetzt in aller
Klarheit und Deutlichkeit der iranischen
Regierung mitzuteilen dass dieses Urteil
Konsequenzen haben muss und für den Fall
dass es vollstreckt werden sollte die
iranisch diplomatischen Beziehungen
abgebrochen werden müssen auf einen
Geschäftsträger herabgestuft werden
müssen und der iranische Botschafter aus
Deutschland ausgewiesen werden muss auch
der Bundeskanzler und andere führende
Politiker haben sich heute zum
Todesurteil gegen den deutschen
Staatsbürger Schorn macht so geäußert es
ist furchtbar was das iranische Regime
macht das bekämpft sein eigenes Volk auf
jeder erdenkliche Weise das haben wir
gemerkt an den Demonstrationen und wie
brutal gegen sie vorgegangen worden ist
die die jungen Leute die Frauen auf den
Weg gebracht haben um für ihre Freiheit
und ein besseres Leben zu kämpfen das
sieht man aber auch in allen Aspekten
der iranischen Justiz es wird eine sehr
klare und harte Antwort geben die
Konkretion obliegt der Außenministerin
die das gerade die das gerade auch
abstimmt aber wenn deutsche Staatsbürger
im Iran mit Schauprozessen dann
verurteilt und hingerichtet werden denn
wir das keine Normalität mehr geben in
den Beziehungen mehr die Außenministerin
heute im Erdbebengebiet ist empört die
Nachrichten aus den Iran ist
schockierend in einem Verfahren was kein
rechtsstaatliches Verfahren ist ein
Todesurteil auszusprechen das
widerspricht jeglichen internationalen
Recht das widerspricht dem
Menschenrechten und deswegen verurteilen
wir das auf Schärfste
[Musik]
sein Leben ist in akuter Gefahr
und wir machen jetzt weiter mit einer
Meldung aus der Wirtschaft die heute
durchaus Hannah für große Kritik gesorgt
hat das kann man so sagen erst kürzlich
hat der Automobilhersteller Mercedes
einen satten Milliardengewinn für das
vergangene Jahr vermeldet und nun
beantragt der Konzern in verschiedenen
Werken Kurzarbeitergeld das sorgt für
Unverständnis weil er die Haller was hat
es damit genau auf sich Mercedes in den
Werken in Bremen und Untertürkheim
tageweise Kurzarbeit ein der Grund sein
Lieferschwierigkeiten das Unternehmen
argumentiert dass das Kurzarbeitergeld
eine Versicherungsleistung ist für die
Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer seit
Jahrzehnten einzahlen und nicht gerade
wenig wie Mercedes vorrechnen also ja
der Autobauer bewegt sich im
gesetzlichen Rahmen ist außerdem auch
den Interessen seiner Aktionäre
verpflichtet freilich ist das schwer
vermittelbar wenn ein Unternehmen gerade
fast 15 Milliarden Euro Gewinn gemacht
hat dann hat das schon einen faden
Beigeschmack doch Anspruch hat wer ein
die finanzielle Lage spielt keine Rolle
das Gesetz gibt es also her vielleicht
müsste man da mal ansetzen in Frankfurt
ließen sich die Börsianer heute durch
nichts die fasnachtslaune verderben denn
egal wie die Kurse stehen am
Faschingsdienstag wird auf dem Parkett
traditionell gefeiert frei nach dem
Motto wieder den tierischen Ernst all
der guten Laune zum Trotz konnte der DAX
selbst nicht mithalten beendet den Tag
mit einem halben Prozent im Minus und da
Börse ist man die Tage eher
zurückhaltend weil man befürchte dass
die Notenbanken weiter an der
Zinsschraube drehen könnten um die
Inflation in Schach zu halten der
Hintergrund aber ist ein positiver
robuste Konjunkturdaten deuten auf einer
Erholung der Wirtschaft hin immerhin
vielen Dank Valerie nach Frankfurt
morgen beginnt die zweite
Verhandlungsrunde im Tarifkonflikt des
öffentlichen Dienstes von Bund und
Kommunen und um den Druck zu erhöhen
haben zahlreiche Beschäftigte heute
erneut ihre Arbeit niedergelegt in
Hannover standen Busse und Bahnen still
in anderen Städten wurden unter anderem
Kitas und Kliniken bestreicht die
Gewerkschaften fordern für die rund 2,5
Millionen Beschäftigten 10,5% mehr Lohn
mindestens aber monatlich 500 Euro mehr
das lehnen die Arbeitgeber ab
zum Start ins WM-Jahr ist die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft der Frauen bei
ihrem ersten Länderspiel auf Schweden
getroffen das eher holprige Testspiel in
Duisburg endete unentschieden mit 0:0
unter den rund 20.000 Fans im Stadion
saß auf Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz wolle
er seine Wertschätzung für den
Frauenfußball zum Ausdruck bringen hieß
es
die Film- und Fernsehwelt trauert um
Nadja Tiller die Schauspielerin ist im
Alter von 93 Jahren in Hamburg gestorben
ihren internationalen Durchbruch feierte
Tiller mit dem Skandalfilm das Mädchen
Rosemarie indem sie 1958 eine
Frankfurter Edelprostituierte
verkörperte hillar drehte mehr als 120
Filme und Serien und stand bis ins hohe
Alter auf Theater Bühnen oftmals an
ihrer Seite ihr Mann weiter Gilla die
beiden galten in den 50er und 60er
Jahren als das Traumpaar des deutschen
Films
Filme sollen Welten erschaffen die einen
berühren entführen und verführen diese
Kunst beherrscht Regisseur und Produzent
Steven Spielberg keine Frage Blockbuster
wie der weiße Hai oder aber auch
Schindlers listig
it Indiana Jones viele viele mehr
Jurassic Park oder aber auch minority
Reports sind ja Belege dafür jetzt aber
wagt sich der Mann der Filmgeschichte
geschrieben hat an seiner eigene
Geschichte mit seinem neuesten Film die
Fable mans versucht er die Lehre zu
füllen die sich nach dem Tod seiner
Eltern irgendwie aufgetan hat sagt er
was sagt Nadja nasser die nicht nur den
Film sondern auch ein sehr besonderen
Auftritt gesehen hat
Steven Spielberg gefeiert auf dem roten
Teppich der Berlinale der
Meisterregisseur freute sich sichtlich
wieder hier zu sein in Berlinale Palast
wartete schon der goldene ehrenbär auf
ihn und er der bereits wirklich fast
alles gewonnen hat sagte er sei auf
diesen Preis besonders stolz
ich muss wohl ein paar Dinge richtig
gemacht haben die letzten 55 Jahre aber
diese Ehre einen Preis für mein
Lebenswerk zu bekommen zwingt mich auch
dazu etwas zu tun was ich nicht oft tue
über mich zu reflektieren und dass ich
in Berlin geehrt werde auf einem der
renommiertesten Festivals der Geschichte
ist ein unglaublicher Höhepunkt in
meinem Leben
Filme sind Träume
[Musik]
die du niemals vergisst in seinem
neuesten Film die Fable mans erzählt
Spielberg jetzt von seiner Kindheit und
Jugend und seinen Anfängen als Regisseur
die Lichter verändern wir alles aussieht
eine filmische Liebeserklärung an seine
Familie die Mutter Künstlerseele wie er
der Vater Computerpionier
in dieser Familie konkurriert die
Wissenschaft mit der Kunst und es ist
eine Liebeserklärung an das Kino die mir
schon früh verfallen war
ich wollte schon immer die Geschichte
meiner Mutter meines Vaters und meiner
Schwestern erzählen und von diesem Kampf
zwischen Kunst und Familie darüber habe
ich schon mein ganzes Leben nachgedacht
das steckt in all meinen Filmen deswegen
sind alle sehr persönlich aber noch in
keinem ging es so konkrete meine eigenen
Erfahrungen in die fabelmans erinnert er
an seine ersten filmversuche und zitiert
sich Augenzwinkern selbst wie die
berühmte fahrradszene aus it der
Außerirdische
im Rahmen der Hommage zeigt die
Berlinale auch sie wieder die großen
Spielberg Klassiker die sich tief in
unsere kollektive Psyche eingegraben
haben
der weiße Hai aus dem Jahr 1975
[Musik]
oder der Film Schindlers Liste für den
er zwei seiner drei Oscars bekam und der
den jüdischen Regisseur zu seinem
größten Projekt neben seiner Filmarbeit
brachte die shower Foundation die
Geschichten von Überlebenden des
Holocaust sammelt
das ist für mich bis heute das
Wichtigste dass je aus einem Kinofilm
resultierte ich bin darauf sehr stolz
und arbeite immer noch sehr aktiv mit
der goldene ehrenbär für einen der
erfolgreichsten Regisseure unserer Zeit
der Höhepunkt der diesjährigen Berlinale
tja und sein neuer Film zeigt ganz
offenbar die Schönheit und den Schmerz
von Verlust und Liebe sollte man
vielleicht gesehen haben ja und dann
hätten wir hier noch eine weitere
Empfehlung nämlich unser heute journal
Update gegen Mitternacht mit Nazan
göktemir das was von uns machen sie es
gut wo auch immer sie sind tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ungewöhnlich mild
und teilweise zu trocken vor allem im
Südwesten Deutschlands so ist es derzeit
auch wenn jetzt etwas Regen dazu kommt
dieses Tief hier nähert sich und seine
Kaltfront bringt dann morgen am späten
Abend etwa 9 Ring von Westen her aber
die großen Mengen sind nicht zu erwarten
schauen wir in die kommende Nacht da
gibt es noch etwas Regen das Lästern in
den Frühstunden nach und dann ist es
auch im Norden trocken so wie im Süden
und teilweise bildet sich ja auch Nebel
und dort wo der Nebel auftritt ist es
teilweise auch am kältesten null Grad
nach Südosten hin -2 am Alpenrand das
ist die kälteste Ecke und 7 Grad hier in
der norddeutschen Tiefe Ebene noch unter
den etwas dichteren Wolken und morgen
dann im Norden weiterhin dicht bewölkt
erst einmal trocken nach südenen nach
Nebelauflösung durchaus auch sonnige
Abschnitte zum Nachmittag kommt dann von
Westen neue bewölkungen auf westlich des
Rheins Regen und auch Richtung Emsland
Temperaturen dazu 5 Grad am kühlsten
Richtung Ostsee aber sonst mit 10 bis 15
Grad deutlich zu mild für die Jahreszeit
die nächsten Tage werden nasser aber
viel Regen wird es nicht sein immer
wieder etwas 6 bis 13 Grad am Donnerstag
am Freitag sind die Schneefallgrenze und
in den Mittelgebirgen müssen wir
durchaus mit Schnee rechnen bei 3 bis 11
Grad Samstag noch ein bisschen kühler
bei zwei bis acht Grad und damit ein
schöner Abend